In a general sense,
the purpose of a company or
other organization is to create value.
That value can be physical or
digital, intellectual or social, but
most companies or organizations
are not made with an idea of hey,
I want to invest a lot of money and
waste a lot of employees'
time to make something that is
completely useless and worthless.
To create value, first you need
an idea for a product or service but
having an idea isn't nearly enough.
Customers don't pay for just ideas.
They want to see something that does
what they need, a functioning product,
a working service.
An idea that you don't actually
ship is nothing but vapor water.
There are often a lot of people involved
in taking a product or even just
one feature from idea to delivery and
these people have to communicate.
They have to pass the product to be
from one person or team to another for
design implementation,
testing and delivery.
And, in the software business,
organizations doing these things have
often fallen into a particular
pattern or anti-pattern.
It's a pattern that can
really get in the way.
This classic organizational structure
has strict borders between development,
quality assurance,
operations and other groups involved
in delivering a product to the user.
One team finishes their part then passes
the product in it's current shape to
the next department for
the next step and
no matter how efficient the process
within single departments,
if there are high walls in between them
problems and inefficiencies creep in.
All too often, there's not a lot of
communication between departments and
the attitude might be, throw it over
the wall it's not our problem anymore,
we met our deadline.
And if the customer at the end
throws the product back saying,
this is not what I wanted,
then a nasty cycle of blame can start.
This kind of organization can
have a lot of different problems.
It tends to be slow and
ineffective at delivery.
It can't learn from failures because
people are blaming one another.
It's hard to make changes especially
large and sweeping changes.
Operational problems tend to
stack up and become worse and
everybody involved is pretty unhappy.
These were challenges that a lot of
organizations faced, especially as teams
and the services they ran got larger,
it got harder for them to work together.
Developers and operations teams, both
technical functions in the company, but
with different interests and
cultures, seemed to be
particularly badly affected.
In 2009, a grassroots movement of
practitioners started that became what
is now known as DevOps.
This movement is experience-based,
decentralized and open to all, but
it has gained a lot of traction
in both the open-source world and
in big-enterprise companies and
as the problems its solves are becoming
more and more apparent in more and
more companies, so
is the adoption of DevOps growing.
But what exactly is DevOps and
how does it help?